une autre année une autre journée
achalandé dans les centres commerciaux à
la croche de noël partout au pays
des milliers de consommateurs sont à la
recherche des cadeaux parfaits qu'ils
glisseront sous le sapin
certains ont tout régler en quelques
heures tout à fait terminé tout est là
pour combien vous avez acheté à peu près
jeu pour lui d'autres sont loin d'être
venu à bout de la liste m'agace selon
sondage altus réalisé pour le compte du
conseil québécois du commerce au détail
les ménages québécois dépenseront en
moyenne 6 169 dollars pour la période
des fêtes
cette jeune femme a dépensé environ 200
dollars en prenant bien soin de choisir
ces cadeaux je crois que tous les âges
ce que j'ai fait était nécessaire ils
vont être reçus cette année isabelle
corbett et son conjoint ont fait le
choix de se tenir loin des centres
commerciaux
quand même envie de vivre un noël
différentes audrey moins long moins
chargés de courses de dernière minute
d'emballage de cadeaux
il n'y a ni sapin mikado même pas pour
l'heure quatre garçons alors les enfants
reçoivent des cadeaux à longueur
d'années depuis que les parents sont
dans les commerces à longueur d'année
qui dépensent déjà troupes sont endettés
alors que les familles sont déjà soumis
à ce saut au stress du crédit puis à
trop consommation le cadeau pour cette
famille passait du temps qualité à la
campagne et on leur a quand même bien
expliqué que nous notre cadeau c'était
le
deux semaines dans la forêt puis ça les
intéresse et aime soit on va quand même
faire des activités on fait beaucoup de
plein air les enfants sont bien heureux
du choix de leurs parents et puisque
vous allez en voyage qu'est d'avoir des
cadeaux juste part des activités
pas besoin d'avoir plein de cadeaux à
noël sera rien
ce qu'il souhaite finalement c'est ce
témoigner leur amour sans artifice ici
valérie michaela bayne radio canada
montréal